i think that at the heart of my
philosophy is much more libertarianism
than
uh than uh well that's the fashionable
word these days i guess liber a
conservative is no longer just that he's
a libertarian always has been
because how do we call a liberal you
know someone very profoundly once said
many years ago that if fascism ever
comes to america it'll come in the name
of liberalism and what is fascism
fascism is
private ownership private enterprise but
total government control and regulation
well isn't this the liberal philosophy
the conservative so-called is the one
that says less government get off my
back get out of my pocket
and let me
have more control of my own destiny
hey everybody i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message today is
april 13
2022 and that was one time california
democrat
turned republican
president ronald reagan making some
sense and we've been sitting on that
clip for a while
because i've had this folder of clips
where i just send clips that i see
throughout the day and we have this
massive folder eclipse and i've had this
one kind of sitting there like there's
going to be a day when i want to do a
show that hits
that that just
pounds that idea into the dust and today
is the day that is going to be the theme
of the show
today uh real quick guys i just want to
thank everybody for the huge huge amount
of support that we got yesterday don't
burn this country absolutely killed it i
know i've been doing an awful lot of
promotion for the book and yesterday was
very focused on sales and getting word
out there and everything i thank you
guys for sticking with me we are going
to ease up on some of that so i really
do thank you we hit number one on
basically all the applicable charts on
amazon and we've sold a ton of books and
i'm very excited and i'm more excited to
get the ideas out there than anything
else truly
so the one thing i do want to say
quickly about the book
is of course about the tour because we
are about to head out on the tour quick
reminder the orlando show which was
supposed to be on monday we have delayed
it if you have the tickets don't do
anything yet we have a massive guest
it's the guest it's the guy that i would
want to talk to more than anyone else
i've said too much you'll get an email
soon about the reschedule date and then
we'll get the
tickets out for everybody else so just
hang tight on that so we are kicking off
the tour
next tuesday the 19th at west palm
improv with donald trump jr then i'm in
clearwater with benny johnson andrew
clavin in raleigh north carolina michael
malus in atlanta janmi park in chicago
glenn beck and dallas megan mccain in
d.c megan kelly in west nyack dennis
prager in brea larry elder in oxnard
douglas marie in san jose blake masters
in phoenix and i'm hearing that uh
charlie kirk may join for that one too
and uh brian callan in denver dave
rubin.com
event so i thank you guys i'm psyched to
get back out on the road you know when
we release the last book uh the
the lockdown remember the lockdowns and
the pandemic and that whole thing uh i
had a worldwide tour going for that one
and we had to cancel the entire thing so
i'm excited to get out there and give
you guys the one second hug so the theme
of today's show and i think we've
got a really nice little thread for you
today is okay
if you are a liberal can you vote for
democrats because as i've been saying we
can talk about all these ideas we can
expose the woke you guys get it already
they're bananas they're collectivists
they're marxists they're destroying
everything they're doing it
right they're doing it we just have to
admit it they're doing it but now what
are the answers what are the actual
tangible
answers that we have
in a time of mass destruction what are
the things that you can do in your life
who are the people you can vote for what
are the ideas that will matter and how
do we put all of this stuff into
practice because now it's time to focus
on solutions they've destroyed an awful
lot but those of us that have had enough
of the destruction it's time to start
rebuilding it start it's time to start
thinking a little bit differently about
things and perhaps perhaps and this is
going to be the hardest one and it is
the theme today for my for my good
remaining liberal friends and there are
a few for the for the banged up democrat
that doesn't know which way is up
anymore
for the old new york or cali liberal who
wasn't a complete woke lunatic
what do you do what do you do and bill
maher who i've spent a lot of time
talking about uh over the last couple of
months he just did a three-hour
long interview with joe rogan and like
he often does he makes some sense and
then completely no sense and it doesn't
ever seem to get to the end of the road
so i'm gonna try to drag him there so
bill maher today's show
goes out to you
real quick before we get to that i want
to talk to you guys about fast-growing
trees because spring and summer are the
seasons for finally getting outdoors and
for entertaining pool parties and bbqs
but if your yard looks like a plant
cemetery you're not going to get to
enjoy it as much as you'd like to get
your place looking like a resort easy
and fast with fast growing trees when it
comes to caring for your plants know-how
matters that's why fastgrowingtrees.com
fastgrowingtrees.com experts curate
thousands of plant varieties that will
thrive in your specific climate location
and needs there's no waiting in lines
and no messy cars from hauling plants
all over town because you order online
or over the phone and your plants are
shipped to your door in one to two days
plus their growing and care advice is
available 24 7 whether you're looking
for increased privacy shade or adding
some natural beauty to your yard fast
growing trees have the perfect plants
and the expertise to help you find them
even if you've never had a green thumb
they'll make you feel like you do 1
million home gardeners have already seen
what fastgrowingtrees.com can do for
them and actually i just ordered a whole
bunch because we got this fence here and
i want a little more privacy in the
backyard because occasionally i might
wander around naked it's possible here
in the backyard i've said too much uh
they've got a 30-day alive and thrive
guarantee that you can trust for every
that everything will be healthy for
years to come go to fastgrowingtrees.com
ruben right now and you'll get 15 off
your entire order get 15 off at
fastgrowingtrees.com reuben
fastgrowingtrees.com reuben and now back
to me
all right so the theme today
is
if you get it and if you watch this show
i suspect you do you get we got a big
problem
we have all of the wrong policies being
instituted
we have all of the wrong people in
charge we have a media that lies to us
about everything this is a series of
things that when you combine them turns
into a very very toxic situation well
okay what can we do about it
well
bill maher was on joe rogan a day or two
ago and they discussed a lot of this and
where mar is at when it comes to saying
he's a liberal who the people he's
voting for are
and what is going on with the crazy left
so here uh i think you'll see he
actually makes some sense to me you know
you're don't you think you've gotten
more conservative no i haven't the left
has gotten goofier yes so i seem more
conservative maybe
but like
it's not me who changed yeah i feel i'm
the same guy but five years ago
uh
you know we hadn't spent six trillion
dollars
to stay home five years ago no one was
talking about abolishing
the police
you know there was no talk about uh you
know
pregnant men and you know i mean there
was just
looting was still illegal right
you know and they're crazy there was
just there's so like have i changed no
because if someone had said 20 years ago
i i'm not sure looting is a bad thing i
would have opposed it then see i so i
haven't changed
okay so bill and your peeps who may or
may not be watching i want to give
credit there right you actually haven't
changed that much your brand of
liberalism which is a brand of
liberalism that is is quite worthy it is
the same classical liberalism that this
country was founded upon
individual rights equality for all
these are good ideas using logic and
reason to solve problems the government
shouldn't do absolutely everything
these are good ideas and actually in
many ways you have not changed but he
says the left has gotten goofier now of
course that is correct
the the progressive movement which is
wildly ill-liberal
has destroyed liberalism and this is
where i think the disconnect comes with
bill so okay if you're a good liberal
but everyone on your side of the aisle
all the people that you've promoted on
your show all the candidates that you've
supported all the democrats in essence
if you've always gone with those people
and then suddenly you look around and
you go boy 90 of the people that i
associate with are completely insane and
are ushering in bad ideas he lists out a
few of them say abolish the police or
men can get pregnant or that looting
should suddenly be legal all of these
things if it's all of the people that
call themselves liberals or call
themselves lefties then although you may
not have changed perhaps there is
something wrong with the root idea of
liberalism and this is not something as
i've said before that i that i come to
lightly as someone that has considered
myself a liberal my entire life the the
basic ideas of a john stewart mill
liberalism of thomas jefferson
liberalism
those ideas that ushered in this country
are
basically the right ideas but perhaps
now they're missing something perhaps in
an age of massive intolerance and this
woke disease perhaps liberalism because
it puts tolerance above all else well
faux tolerance i should say
perhaps that weak underbelly has allowed
intolerance to come in so this is a
problem so you can sit there and say
i am a liberal still
but if everyone that you vote for
meaning democrats right the guy has
never voted for a republican he'll tell
you he hates critical race theory but
although he doesn't live in virginia did
he publicly support glenn younkin he'll
tell you that florida is doing
everything right
but he makes a point of what he's saying
but i'm not going to move to florida and
he won't say that he's going to support
ron desantis so this is the disconnect
that the last liberals have and here
today i am coming
i'm coming open
and welcoming that it's time for you
guys to get on board
it's time enough's enough it is time to
get on board so if you think i'm making
it up that that
conservatives generally have been
warning about these things and usually
write about these things so the same
liberal position now is that lockdowns
are bad and actually men can't give
birth in a bunch of it but conservatives
and and it's not even conservative it's
just sane people like it's really not
liberal versus conservative anymore it's
basically people with a completely
insane set of views versus people with
some sane set of views and we may
disagree on
you know some where those parameters are
at exactly but roughly sane people
versus awful insane people okay
uh
the same people have been right about a
lot they've been right about the
lockdowns they've been right about what
was coming with the gender stuff they've
been right about what was coming with
critical race there and everything else
you may remember this clip on bill
maher's very show
two years ago when dennis prager went on
to say
in essence that uh soon the left will be
saying or they're saying it already but
it's really coming that men will be able
to menstruate here we go the left wing
is infinitely larger than one person i
don't choose one left wing person who
tells a lie
the left wing says i'll give you
gigantic lies that the united states is
a racist country this this is a lie this
is a gargantuan lie this is the least
racist multi-cultural multi-ethnic
country in the history of the world that
these people believe it is proof to me
about how effective lying
this is an unbelievably non-racist
country have you people been to asia or
they have something
documented of course there's i'm a jew
okay there are anti-semites in america
it is a giant lie that america is
anti-semitic i taught jewish history at
brooklyn college i know it i wrote two
books on judaism this is the least
anti-semitic country jews have ever
lived in to say america's anti-semitic
is a lie to say it is racist is a lie
okay these are giant left-wing lies
we're talking about degrees to say that
men can menstruate is a lie and that is
now that is what is said
wait wait wait where did that i never
just
that how do you allow men biological men
to run against women in in the races in
connecticut and set all the high school
records okay but that's they're called
okay so everything that dennis prager
said there was absolutely true dennis
prager actually came to my house right
after that show and we had a lovely
dinner that evening with his wife sue
sue love you um so dennis prager was
warning about all of this stuff and of
course when he says that the country is
the least racist country ever bill bill
says well there's some racism but of
course it's just a meaningless position
it is a meaningless position to say
there is some racism in america there is
some racism everywhere and bill uh
dennis's response have you gone to asia
i mean guys you should do a little
googling if you like to google or
whatever search engine you use about the
inter
racist attitudes asian people have about
other asian people from country to
country it's rather extraordinary how
the chinese feel about the japanese how
the japanese feel about the taiwanese
how the the whole thing the koreans feel
about this that the other okay
the idea that we are the racist when we
have relentlessly fought over the
hundreds of years of our country to
eliminate racism and we pretty much
almost got there until the last couple
years where the left is bringing it back
but the audience feels very
uncomfortable they're good liberals we
must be racist we're good liberals we we
have to be bad we feel guilty because
we're successful and decent we must be
racist not not us though it's those
other people it's those other crazy
right-wing people so of course
dennis is completely right about that
and exposes it and then when he brings
up the gender stuff
and this thing about women menstruating
bill says well i missed that story and
dennis says no it's happening right now
and he brings up the point that we now
all know like what have we been talking
about for the last couple of months
about this endless assault assault it's
the only word to use of women when it
comes to women's sports and now
biological men leah thomas destroying
all of these actual girls because he's
not a girl
in women's swimming
uh dennis says look it up dennis says
look it up when bill is so shocked that
people could be saying this about
menstruation well you're not going to
believe it we did and here's what google
says
when you
search can men menstruate having a
period is not a feminine thing and
people of all genders menstruate
including non-binary people agender
people and even plenty of men
exclamation point
menstruation doesn't change anything
about your gender it's just a thing that
some bodies do
that is pure
bull [ __ ]
if blood started pouring
out of my genitals this would be a
problem and it would have nothing to do
with menstruation
i hope my mom's not watching today
this is absolutely
insane that is the first answer that
pops up when you when you google can men
menstruate so now understand what's
happening here and i'm laying out a case
i'm laying out a case like a like a
lawyer down south do you understand here
uh
the liberals the bill maher liberals and
again this is not an attack on bill i'm
trying to help the guy actually
you can't get everything wrong then to
and then attack all of the people who
tell the truth then two years later
repeat what they say without a bit of a
mia culpa without i'm sorry dennis
prager without a oh i voted in for all
the wrong people and everything else
so next we're going to talk more about
uh the woke disney groomers and the
confusion over don't say gay and the
rest of it uh but real quick i want to
get to bullion max you know as inflation
surpasses highs not seen in 40 years the
value of the dollar is decreasing with
every passing day ain't that the truth
you're paying more at the pump the
grocery store for cars and for housing
face it your paper money is worth less
it just is friends the time couldn't be
any better for my new sponsor bullion
max bullion max is a direct to consumer
precious metals retailer who can help
you diversify into gold and silver it's
a hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
crisis and here's why people love
bullion max they're owned by veterans in
precious in the precious metal space
offers some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website i want to
help get you started so i worked out a
special offer with them just for you
get bullion max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com
dave this kit includes five of the most
desirable silver products to invest in
including a silver american eagle and a
silver australian kangaroo i do love the
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com dave now and now back to
me okay so bill maher continued on uh
the joe rogan experience or program or
podcast
talking about disney and woke-ism and
sort of where it's all coming from
do you think that the way it's going
right now with late night television
where you you everyone has to be
political is that what the audience
wants or is that what the executives in
the studio wants are they like who is
are they one step behind
like what where where is the the mandate
coming from is it the person who's the
host who says you know what i know works
in this town if i want to keep working i
have to be like outwardly left-leaning
progressive political look it's i think
it's coming from both because
corporations in america now
um are they're leaning in
they're leaning into woke
hardcore they're they're petrified of
some kind of backlash i mean you see
with disney now corporations i think yes
are always going to want to and look i'm
glad they are progressive thinking of
course like with everything on the left
these days they just take it too far
aha
the end the last line there that was
what i'm glad they're for progressive
thinking it's a meaningless statement at
this point what do you mean you're glad
that corporations are for progressive
thinking if you mean by that that you
are glad that corporations are for
equality
if there was a group of people who
couldn't vote let's say or a group of
people who couldn't get married or a
group of people who had some issue that
they could not legally
partake in because of the color of their
skin or the nature of their reality well
then that would be something that we
should progress to
but then what he says is but of course
they go overboard well yes again this
perhaps has something to do with the
weakness of a purely secular liberalism
that if that liberalism completely
detached from something like belief
something that is bigger than us
something that connects us to god-given
rights not state given rights will
always leak into the banana's lunacy and
speaking of the bananas lunacy we've
showed you this video this is uh disney
animation director latoya ravenew
talking about how she leaks her bananas
crazy lefty nonsense into children's uh
movies and television shows on disney
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so let's have
these two characters kiss let's in the
background like i was just wherever i
could just basically adding queerness to
like no one would stop me and no one was
trying to stop me
okay i am so tired of saying this but i
i don't have a problem with gay people
i'm married to one okay
um i like some gay people i don't like
actually there's a lot of gay people i
don't like quite frankly but there's a
lot of straight people i don't like
either i don't choose to like someone or
associate with someone whether
depending on their sexuality i like
people based on individuality oh you're
gay and you're cool and fun let's hang
out oh you're gay and you're a
relentless harping prick i don't like
you and i would apply those same
standards to straight people the problem
here with what latoya is doing is no one
is bringing their children to disney
movies
to be indoctrinated into anything so
this has nothing to do really in some
essence this doesn't really have to do
with indoctrinating kids into gayness
specifically i don't i don't even really
think that's a thing i think you can
confuse kids in a lot of different ways
but that's not really what this is about
this is that when you thought when all
of us when we were kids when you went to
the movie theater or when when you
watched i remember my grandparents when
i was maybe five or six uh
babysitting for us my parents went out
and we watched uh cinderella vhs tape of
cinderella it was like did we think did
my grandparents think oh this should
indoctrinate them in some way into some
ideas or was it just a fantastical story
that you actually might get some
timeless lessons from because you used
to get some timeless lessons from
fairy tales and from these movies and
things but now they're telling you we
are injecting our ideas my not so secret
gay agenda as she says this woman works
on a on a disney show called the proud
family by the way so they're telling you
what they do and i link this to the
previous clip about bill maher because
he is in essence supporting the
politicians who support all this and
then saying oh but they do go too far
well yes they do go too far and then
they destroy
the liberalism
that you
say you are for okay uh this is
liberalism without any emergency break
that in essence is what it is and every
set of ideas should have some sort of
fail-safe in there to go oh we here are
our set of ideas and it doesn't mean
everyone has to believe the exact same
things but we have to have some
guardrails around these ideas otherwise
we don't even we actually don't have a
set of ideas i think that's what bill
maher is unfortunately up against and
and and it's baked in it's baked in
while they why they don't have these
guard rails so now let's talk about how
the media plays a role in this um cnn's
brian stelter and you know this guy he
is the worst sort of corporate nothing
who is is nothing more than a potato
propagandist and listen to the way we
played one of these clips we've got a
little something
of extra for you here but listen to the
way he frames
the conversation about what's happening
with disney and again he is a
progressive he is a lefty he is a
democrat
obviously
in the united states we're seeing a
theme of the midterm elections emerging
it's the way you can see a wave start to
form far from shore before it breaks on
the beach the theme the talking point on
the right is about protecting kids from
the dangers of
the walt disney company
really
but disney's just a stem a stand-in it's
just a symbol for something bigger a
conservative backlash to growing
acceptance of gay and transgender people
a conservative fear that traditional
beliefs are being trampled on and there
are entire networks that program to this
fear and many politicians that react to
it that's the story here opponents say
they're really actually anti-gay bills
and it's easy to picture this battle
continuing right through the midterm
elections but for folks who aren't
partisan warriors this battle is
incredibly disheartening
i spoke with a disney executive who's
caught in the middle of it right now and
they said you know disney's brand for
decades has been family friendly and has
been gay friendly and that hasn't been
in conflict
that need not be in conflict
but the media organs that profit from
conflict are on a crusade now working
overtime to demonize disney claiming the
company is indoctrinating and
sexualizing children through movies and
tv shows
felter you pathetic potato
the woman i just showed you a woman who
writes
these movies these tv shows she said
she's indoctrinating children it's not
the right wing media the scary
right-wing media or those scary
christian people who are saying it
they're repeating it because it's the
people themselves that are doing it that
are saying we are indoctrinating kids so
they had three chirons did you notice
the chiron is the little the little
blurb under the story as he's talking
they had three chirons that were all
lies uh why the right wing media is
targeting mickey mouse i mean does that
strike you as an honest assessment of
what's going on here that the right-wing
media is really going after mickey mouse
yes we're going after mickey mouse and
we want to take out donald duck and
goofy's head on a stick that's really
what this is all about if these freaks
had not done all of this and moved on
people's children do you think anyone
would be going after them so that one's
a lie then the next current says lgbt
rights are the latest target of
right-wing media no not true lie stelter
why we're gonna send this video to
stelter can we get a contact at cnn
we've tried to get him on the show
before now i know he's not going to do
it but uh i want to send this video to
selter stelter this is for you if you
are so into this idea that state
employees should have private
conversations with six-year-olds about
sexuality and gender identity what you
should do on your show is bring on
someone else's child and have a
conversation with them about gender
identity have that conversation live on
air i'll retweet you you'll get some
clicks and you get no clicks by the way
little sidebar to this whole story did
you see this thing where cnn they
launched the cnn plus thing did you hear
about this this was their digital
network in essence to compete with
people like me like to complete with to
compete with the people that are
actually getting clicks and have some
influence these days they were going to
put a billion dollars into it they put a
couple hundred million they got ten
thousand paying subscribers which half
of those have to be uh cnn or disney
employees whatever it is um it's just so
pathetic nobody's paying attention to
these people and then the third chi run
right wing stars claim disney is
indoctrinating why i already hit that
one i mean it's it's just
everything they say is a lie but stelter
i will retweet you
sit there with someone else's first
grader second grader talk to them about
sexuality and uh show us how how morally
right you are and how evil the right
wing is and then we'll go from there but
okay we're laying out the case here and
uh let's continue with the prosecution
of the case uh kovit now kovit it's
funny because some of the uh enlightened
liberals or whatever you want to call
them they've in the last few weeks or
maybe two months or so they've sort of
come out against some of the mandates
and the draconian policies and things
and i think what you'll find here
uh is that uh bill maher and joe rogan
are gonna make some sense on this kind
of thing i probably have but it's like i
don't know
i would trust it it came from the cdc if
they if they personally admitted yes
this is or the people who make the
vaccine
um anybody else i don't know but then
again they could be lying i also don't
tell them don't trust them to tell me
the truth about whether they did put it
in there
and i don't know what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that
so don't tell me things like just do
what we say don't question it
when have we ever been wrong
a lot all the time been wrong a lot and
you just don't know a lot so just don't
tell me well we are perfectly certain
that this vaccine is safe or we are
perfectly certain that these x-rays are
a low dose and they won't you don't
[ __ ] know that you don't know what
all these different things these this
like 50 000 chemicals we have in our
body that we didn't have 100 years ago
you don't know what the interchange of
all these elements is doing to me and me
personally it might be different than
you
so just don't have that attitude of just
get it in you
yes we are the people who know
not just that but they're making insane
amounts of profit from that we're yes
we're supposed to pretend that they've
been honest
about the risks of things in the past
okay i think rogan really hits the key
part there right these people who are
making an awful lot of money and stand
to make a future awful lot of money and
who have
put in legal language so they'll never
be held to account if anything's wrong
with any of these vaccines or anything
else like perhaps that's what this is
really about but but mar is basically
making sense although the first thing he
says there i would trust the cdc or the
people who make the vaccines and then he
kind of realizes what he said there and
he goes but they could be lying so why
should we trust them i mean two years
after this whole thing do you really
trust the cdc do you really trust the
vaccine makers i'm not saying they're
all liars i'm not saying that they're
all evil and i have no doubt that there
are good employees who work there and i
ha and i have no but we know that
they've even fudged the numbers even
over the last couple weeks they fudged
the numbers related to deaths and
infections and a whole bunch other stuff
remember there was one thing what was
the line that they used about the
numbers that they screwed up related to
covid deaths they it was an accounting
error or something they forgot to carry
the one in one of those things or it was
what they called a clerical error
it was a database error something like
that um so mark sort of says the right
thing at first he was like well uh
well
the the cdc i would trust them but then
he realizes oh no why should i just
trust them but the problem is liberals
put too much faith in big institutions
above them i think probably because
they're trying to find other gods
because usually they don't believe in
gods but something about believing in
systems and believing in something is
very important to the human experience
so you can run around saying you're an
atheist but then to go oh but cdc said
something i have to believe it but then
he also has a logical brain and a
logical brain goes wait just because
they said it probably not true possibly
not true hey i'm still back here
okay fine but he sort of got it but once
again it's like okay you're getting it
two years later because when there was a
cost to getting it over the last two
years when many of us were screaming
that there should be no mandates that
you should not be forcing children to
wear masks that it should be up to the
individuals and all the things where
were you bill maher and again this is
not an attack on bill maher this is this
is a genuine this is a genuine hand out
of like let's let's do this let's get to
the end let's start building the new
world you should be part of the new
world obviously but when there was a
cost to having any of the opinions that
you now have you didn't have those
opinions you were not going after fauci
you were not
was he loudly screaming i mean please
someone find me a video where he was
ranting and raving against mandates i'll
gladly show that video tomorrow and i'll
apologize but when a whole bunch of us
were where were you now it's very easy
to say it right it's the easiest
possible thing to say
but you believe in the cdc that's what
you're saying you believe in the in
these big institutions well here's video
from uh you know a year plus ago about
what the people who were running these
things felt about all of us this is lord
fauci
so are there countries that you the
other countries that seem to be doing
well that then weren't doing so are
there countries now that hold up as
models for
you know pretty good response to this
you know the answer is yes but right now
it seems that every country is suffering
we are often compared
with countries that are not comparable
to us we are not a little island of five
million people that we can shut off
we're not a country that would accept if
a ruler tells us you must do this i was
talking with our uk colleagues
just today who was saying the uk is very
similar to where we are now in outbreak
because each of our countries have that
independent spirit but we don't want to
be told what to do
well i understand that but now is the
time to do
what you're told
oh the laugh there just just an evil man
he is an evil man and he does not
deserve your respect and he does not
deserve your attention and he certainly
doesn't deserve your rights your
god-given rights that he has no
authority over um but my guys just did a
quick cursory look and again if anyone
can prove me wrong on this i'll gladly
play it tomorrow there was really no
criticism uh by bill maher of fouchy or
the cdc until january of this year
that's when things really started
changing because that's when omicron
swept through the country all these
people got coveted me included and then
suddenly people's feelings about it
maybe after two years of this insanity
it just broke enough people that they
were like enough listening to these
people so when there was a cost of
having a hard opinion and i can link
this back to the dennis prager clip
before what dennis prager was saying two
years ago it was absolutely true it was
absolutely true but bill maher was
mocking him for it when there's no cost
it becomes very easy for the liberals
and this is all the liberal this is all
the remaining liberals whoever there is
and again it's a plea to you guys let's
go let's go we got cookies we're good
it's all good
um but all of the conservatives were
being yelled at because we're
anti-vaxxers and we're mean and we want
grandma to die and ron desantis is a
maniac and all of those things
well
i thought we should link this to a
little bit of what happened because of
these policies over the last couple
years and do you remember what the
liberals brought in to this country do
you remember what was going on in the
blue cities in the blue states and
speaking of blue cities philadelphia
right now reinstituting re-instituting
their mass mandate right now as
unbelievable as that sounds but it was
all the test people and they did it once
and they'll do it again well do you
remember what was happening in our
cities i remember
eerily quiet in the city that never
sleeps
the trains are still running but no
one's at the station the state of new
york now in lockdown
the number starts to go up tighten the
valve
if the number doesn't slow down
close the valve
the number of cases in the state now
surpassing 7 000 putting immense
pressure on hospitals and critical
supplies
ventilators
are to this war
what missiles were to world war ii we
need ventilators
with the hospital system under
increasing stress the death toll
continues to rise at an alarming rate
among the fatalities four members of the
same family a 73 year old woman in new
jersey and three of her children
across the country california's 40
million residents also hunkered down as
a statewide lockdown came into place the
notorious 405 highway in los angeles
free-flowing while police patrolled
empty beaches for violators
while police patrolled empty beaches for
violators and they literally did that in
los angeles the famous video of the
police the fat police officer chasing
the young surfer who was alone on the
beach
on a beautiful 80 degree day
swimming in the pacific in los angeles
they filled the famous skate ramp
remember that at venice beach venice
beach which was one once one of the
coolest places we had in all of the
united states it was like this hippie
utopia for whatever level of
utopia we could have and such a cool
place of music and food and culture and
all sorts of different people coming
together it ended up becoming a
crackdown basically and i do not
recommend any of you ever go to venice
beach it's it's actually quite evil i
have a i have a good buddy who lives in
venice beach in a in a pretty nice house
and he can't sell it because nobody
wants he's like basically trying to give
it away a seriously nice house and he
can't give it away because nobody wants
to live in that [ __ ] but this is
what burning a country looks like right
and we don't want to burn this country
well that's what we don't want to do but
i suspect it is what some people want to
do and it's what some people
accidentally vote for when they call
themselves good liberals while mocking
all of those mean conservatives now and
i just want you to think for one second
and the reason i played that video is
because i think we have to not forget
right am i what am i always talking
about we have to not forget what
happened over these last two years they
try to make us forget we move on to
ukraine and we move on to this and that
and we forget what these people and
their policies did to us and if you
think that it's not coming back well as
i just said
philadelphia is putting on masks again
and so be it have your cheesesteak with
a mask cheesesteak mask cheesesteak mask
cheesesteak max okay
but there's some other video coming out
of shanghai china right now that is
absolutely insane and i really thought
about whether i wanted to show this
video or not because it's so profoundly
evil what's happening there and i don't
want to be alarmist
but i think it's important to know what
happens when a fully authoritarian
government
uh what full fascism
which is what they're trying to usher in
here
communism marxism i don't even care what
you call it at this point when full
government control over the people is
allowed uh here's what's happening
there's a compilation video
of what's happening right now in china
over what they're saying is now the next
version of omicron
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you're seeing a whole bunch of
different stuff in that compilation
you're seeing a child that that first
video was a child who had been separated
from his parents from what i understand
just wandering around trying to find
some assistance the screaming that you
were hearing those were in buildings in
shanghai those are people who have been
locked in their apartments they no
longer have food in many cases they
don't have running water they are
literally starving to death people are
dying in their apartments there are
other videos we didn't want to show you
people are jumping from their windows
because they are sick of starving to
death because the government has decided
that they should have a zero covered
policy this is only because people
allowed the government to have too much
power over their lives and governments
do horrible things it's just a sick
twisted part of humanity it just is um
so and then of course what you're seeing
there is rioting related to food and and
a whole bunch more okay so what was the
point of today's show the point of
today's show is there is a way to stop
this and we can do it we cannot burn
this country we can choose not to burn
this country but the sane liberals the
moderate democrats you might be the key
to this whole thing and i don't know how
many of you watch this show anymore i i
suspect a bunch of you do well i know a
bunch of you do but i think you have to
start speaking up you might be the key
to this whole thing the conservatives
the libertarians
whatever they they basically get it we
know which way they're gonna vote and we
know that a lot of people are shifting
that way right here in florida alone
when desantis came in uh there were
about 200 000 more registered democrats
than republicans last i heard there's
about 90 000 more registered republicans
than democrats we're going to see this
happen we saw what happened in virginia
with yunkan okay but the key at a
national level if this country is to
continue is that if you are a decent
democrat if you are a decent liberal if
you are bill maher you can no longer
vote for people who are destroying the
ideas that you purport to believe in you
cannot vote for democrats anymore you do
not have to be a republican but you
cannot be a democrat it's not that hard
this is not rocket science we have to
save this country we have to do it right
now the democratic party must be
destroyed we must get rid of all of them
we don't have to jail them we don't have
to ban them we don't have to put them in
gulags but we have to get them out of
power and we have to put the power back
in the hands of the people that's what
we have to do and now in summation how
do we do that it's actually quite simple
good people must just stand up the
individual must stand up and say here i
am and this is what i believe in and i
will not give power to people who do not
deserve it so we have one of those guys
in florida his name is ron desantis and
for two years he stood against the
entire machine
and he surrounded himself with people
like our incredible
surgeon general here latapo who were
willing to fight against the machine and
fight against the cdc and fight against
all of the forces that we seemingly
think are impossible to stop and yet we
seemingly did it here and it's and i say
seemingly because
we've done it for now but the forces are
going to keep coming and that's why we
we can't just sit back and say oh we did
it we're good to go no we must we must
focus and really understand how we did
it and why we did it and how we're going
to stop it uh so here's uh desantis on
15 days to slow the spread a year and a
half ago we started with 15 days to slow
the spread and now it's gone to
get jabbed or lose your job and today's
osha rule a very long time coming we
were we were waiting for it that was
issued if you look at it
here it is it's almost 500 pages and so
we're supposed to be a government of
laws not a government of men
this is 500 pages of a government of a
bureaucracy a government that is being
run by executive edict not in accordance
with the typical constitutional
processes and the state of florida is
going to respond and we will combat the
osha rule
he's just one guy doing the right thing
and then one guy doing the right thing
inspires someone else to do the right
thing and someone else to do the right
thing and in a world of algorithms and
retweets you can inspire an awful lot of
people to do the right thing so then
desantis continued this is yesterday in
response to what's going on now in
philly with the remasking and what's
going on in china as long as i sit in
the chair in which i sit
no floridian will be restricted
mandated or locked down in any possible
way
what's hilarious about that of course is
his critics will say that he's the
fascist he's the one who hates freedom
and it's like man he's trying to free
you people you live in the freest state
in the union a union that is struggling
right now right a union that is is is
quaking
because of some bad forces
but now let's link this thing
back to the beginning what was ronald
reagan talking about
conservatives oppose fascism
conservatives opposed the idea that
corporations could line themselves up
with government
to push down on the rights of people
who is defending the corporations
relative to their power right now it's
the people who are supporting disney
right now
right who's the one standing up against
disney and saying hey disney you don't
get to decide what the children of
florida learn it's the scary
conservative ron desantis it's the scary
conservatives all over the country who
are saying no no no no disney you not
you do not rule over us and we will
fight against you and it's just as
ronald reagan warned and i think that
was around 1983 or so just as ronald
reagan warned it's the liberals through
a combination of corporate power
and government power who are ushering in
fascism all of the bad ideas so bill
maher once again to you
and i suppose to john stewart and to
barry weiss and the few others that are
out there well it's not even a few
others i know there's a chunk of you out
there and the reason i do these videos
is i think if we can just move you we're
good i think we could do it i really do
think we could do it at least at the
state level we could do it you guys just
need to be moved to understand that you
in the name of liberalism are destroying
liberalism and you can sit there and say
i'm a good liberal and all the other
liberals have gone mad
but perhaps you must vote for other
people to defend the very things that
you
believe that is the point
so marr
rogan even even joe rogan do you support
ron desantis yes or no i don't mean to
be a dick but like do you support ron de
santos yes or no why did you leave
california you fled california after 200
million bucks from spotify you didn't
like the taxes that's perfectly fine i
don't like taxes either and you fled
california and you moved to texas where
there's no income tax
so are you
willing to support a republican uh
candidate in texas are you willing to
support aranda santos in florida it
doesn't mean you have to live in the
state with the guy but do you basically
support these people who are do who are
actually doing the things that are
congruent with the way you live your
life uh we've got a great cold close for
you related to all this but i want to do
a couple locals comments before we get
to that uh jay says google is confusing
menstruation with bloody hemorrhoids
my bloody joke from before really uh
seems much worse now
matt says california was mentioned on
your show dave cash in the jar sorry
matt you are completely right and not
only will i put five dollars and again
we're having this internal debate is
this money
to free someone from california to bring
them to florida or is this money perhaps
better used to take a lefty anna navarro
i am told lives somewhere in florida
okay in miami somewhere so maybe this
money should go to get get just get anna
navarro the hell out of this state she
is a crazy person that would perhaps be
a better use of the money although i do
want to save somebody from maybe i'll do
both i don't know we'll figure it out
there's a there's a 10 today so there
you go uh d
i'll donate this money to bill maher
mar you're worth probably at least 100
million bucks but if you need an extra
5k
to like get home to bring it all
together man
there you go
uh dee says love your appearance on
megan kelly i did two hours on the
magnum kelly podcast and siriusxm show
yesterday which you can find on youtube
i just adore megan we we have such a
good rhythm together she's just she's
just a great human being and i love her
so thank you i appreciate that uh
reminder guys i am going on tour please
join me out on the road we kick it off
next tuesday in west palm and then we're
in uh we're bouncing around florida
we're going to texas and new york and
illinois and california and d.c and all
over the place
colorado etc etc daverubin.com
events if you want to play along during
the live chat
as we're doing the show it's
reubenreport.locals.com my interview
where michael knowles hosts the reuben
report and asks me about this very book
uh is up right now on youtube and rumble
and on locals
and finally related to all of this stuff
one man can save us
and it's not one specific man it's one
man
meaning it's you
i just want you to know we really
appreciate our georgians um
if stacey abrams is elected governor of
georgia
i just want to be honest that will be a
cold war between florida and georgia at
that point
i mean i can't have castro to my south
and abrams to my north that'd be a
disaster so i hope you guys take care of
that and we end up